first question I say it gentle because
it's exactly the information that you
need to solve this exact question later
on I mean the reason why the question on
the back is so difficult is you've got
loads in the fish you don't even know
what's relevant here I only give you
three things and there are exactly three
things you need so I cut the area of
triangle so you can see on the diagram
what am i done or the diagram I've
identified what what so that I know what
to put into the half a B sine
teen-oriented for better it's just a
straight substitution that's all that
question really is okay so hopefully you
were able to get to this point pop it
into your calculator and there it is to
one decimal place you happy with that
okay so far so good question - this is
the first curveball so since by next
okay now you can see that the
information you've been given isn't
really quite enough it is current form
this is what the question looks like
when you first visit that's what it
looks like right can you use cosine rule
on this you can't use cosine rule
because if you wanted to so find out
this side you need the opposite angle
and the other two sine and you're kind
of stuck right it's also a ribbon so
therefore I put this in do you see what
I'm doing I've got okay cosine rules out
I D sine rule but in order to get to
this
I need the angle that is opposite so you
can see me working that out in green
I've got the angles of the triangle tr
once you know what that top angle is
again it's some calculator work okay so
my answer was there's my working boy
three points to salvia yeah
now can i square down you're 12 it's off
where I get bit carmakers I wish you to
also know something that I've said about
sense checks and how intrigued you have
the ability to do much better sense
check than you've ever done before if
you worked out this angle in the corner
right 79 degrees
do you notice it's almost identical size
to this angle here just a little bit
bigger right that just a little bit
bigger me you should expect this size
here than opposite to be just a little
bit bigger so this size does that make
sense yeah which is why you're like 43.2
well that's just a little bit bigger
than the 43 that's already vetted that
make sense yes point you point you if
you haven't got this down I will come
back I promise but let's just move on as
a class to the battery okay final size
is the largest angle the trickiest thing
was identifying which angle is it can
you see what I've done
do you see what I've done on the diagram
right the largest angle matches with the
largest size right the longest side
which is that's twelve point one oh it's
off its off it's all you guys know I
want you to have this discussion just
not this minute hold fire
we'll get through if you want the
largest angle you need to know which
one's the largest side and you go
opposite that's the important be
included angle remember that okay
so what do you know what is what you
just have to go through the formula
sheet and you can see I've got all three
sides so cosine rule is sort of
screaming use me use me you just have to
make sure you have the right a B and C
you see that so there's my 12.1 which is
that longest side which is opposite and
then everything else kind of fits into
spots on the left you notice as well I
think it's helpful to have these two
lines here to say okay I hit
but that's not the angle that's cosine
of the angle right because i know i i've
seen equals that I'm like thank God my
calculator told me what the answer is
and then I'd move on but the left-hand
side says cos C which is you need an
extra step to get the egg on top okay so
four degrees to the nearest degree can
we turn over let's do it okay now let me
just pause for a second can I actually
get you to put your pens down I promise
you want plenty of time Ruth I could put
the whole PDF up when I wrote it if
that's what you would benefit from
here's what I want to show you this
diagram has a lot of extra stuff on it
which I didn't add on the first time I
drew it this is what the diagram looks
like it's beginning give that know it's
different events that there we go here
we go okay so when I did Part A this is
what my diagram looks like and I hope
you can see that's pretty much the
middle I can get my Daisy maybe a
question mark but that's pretty much the
minimum you need to actually get that
book do you see it all information from
the questions got the eight got the tree
it's got the berry do you notice to do
the berry you need to have something
that points Lord I forgot a whole
compass rose there that's fine too but a
North is the minimum why not why not
east or west
because true berry start from naught
right so now if we go to join you north
of that you measure around now in the
process of continuing solving the
question I added more stuff on so let me
just put all that stuff back and I will
talk through it as I go
all right so I drew this diagram and I
hope you did too I tried to give you
lots of space for that that was a big
hit you need as much space as you can to
draw a decent diagram puppies did
calculate the distance this is the way I
did what information did I do
I had the eight in the three clearly I'm
going to use that because there other
sides in that triangle ABC but I needed
this extra piece of information have a
look at the diagram what is that what am
i working out and why the angle that I
working out is the it's not just any
angle it's the included angle up here
the corner right this is the angle I
want because AC is opposite that angle
deserve a sense the word you I've got to
270 take away 155 what is 270 what's
irrelevant since that yeah yes I tactic
searches come up here on your diagram do
you see that 270 is all the way around
that's 270 right well to work out the
angle inside the triangle you've got
that purple 270 and you're taking away
so 155 on the outside does that make
sense
so that's why I've got this line of work
you use to find out what ABCs